On May 8, 1828, the man who founded The International
Committee of the Red Cross, Henry Dunant,
was born.
In 1922, almost a century after his birth,
the eighth of May was declared a day dedicated
to the International Red Cross, in this way
honoring its founder.
Dunant’s dream was to prevent and alleviate
human suffering, without discrimination.
Despite being born to wealth, he died in poverty
partially due to his dedication to charitable
work.
He remains one of the greatest humanitarians
in history, but few today know much about
him.
So who was Henry Dunant really?
Henry Dunant was born in Geneva, Switzerland
to wealthy parents.
His father was a successful – and generous
– businessman who early on instilled in
Dunant’s young mind the value of helping
others.
His father and grandfather were men of power
and prestige in Geneva, and had held various
positions such as membership in Geneva’s
governing council, director of a Geneva hospital,
and mayor of a small city near Geneva called
Avully.
As a young man, Dunant was fascinated by the
works of three writers, all of them women:
Harriet Beecher Stowe, Florence Nightingale,
and Elizabeth Fry.
He later stated,
The influence of women is an essential factor
in the welfare of humanity, and it will become
more valuable as time proceeds.
Henry busied himself with a number of charitable
activities.
Anti-Semitism was pretty intense at that time
in Europe, and Dunant worked against this,
particularly encouraging Christians and Jews
to band together.
He also became a member of the Geneva organization
known as the “League of Alms,” whose main
purpose was to provide spiritual and material
assistance to the poor and sick.
He frequently visited Geneva’s jails, where
he tried to rehabilitate and reintegrate prisoners.
Dunant was religious from his earliest youth,
and had felt that religion could be the answer
to many moral issues in society.
Partially motivated by this, he became an
active member of the Young Men’s Christian
Association (YMCA) and co-founded a YMCA in
Geneva in 1852.
He went on to help found the World Alliance
of YMCAs which was first developed in 1855.
Along with his colorful social life and all
his humanitarian efforts, he was prospering
on a professional level too.
In 1849, he was appointed to the Bank of Geneva.
His work there was so impressive that in 1853
he was appointed interim general manager of
the subsidiary company in Algeria, where he
also started his own business.
In 1859, he had to consult with Napoleon III
concerning his business, so he traveled to
northern Italy where Napoleon III was conducting
a military campaign.
This trip changed his life.
On the June 25, 1859, Henry Dunant witnessed
firsthand the tragedy and horrors of war when
he toured the area the day after the Battle
of Solferino, a particularly bloody mutual
slaughter, with tens of thousands of soldiers
left on the battlefield dead or dying.
This traumatic experience had such an impact
that when he returned to Geneva, he wrote
a book about what he had seen, A Memory of
Solferino, which he published at his own expense.
The book was translated into many languages,
and was circulated to most of the influential
leaders and politicians throughout Europe.
A Memory of Solferino made this proposition:
“If the new and frightful weapons of destruction,
which are now at the disposal of the nations,
seem destined to abridge the duration of future
wars, it appears likely, on the other hand,
that future battles will only become more
and more murderous.
Would it not be possible, in time of peace
and quiet, to form relief societies for the
purpose of having care given to the wounded
in wartime by zealous, devoted and thoroughly
qualified volunteers?”
He also stated:
Adoption by all civilized nations of an international
and sacred principle which would be assured
and placed on record by a convention to be
concluded between governments.
This would serve as a safeguard for all official
and unofficial persons engaged in nursing
war victims.
The idea for the foundation of the Red Cross
had been planted in his mind and heart.
After witnessing the direct aftermath of the
battle of Solferino, Dunant dedicated his
time, and much of his money, to the relief
of mankind from the pain incurred in war.
He traveled to every major city in Europe
to spread the message of the destructive and
inhuman nature of war, and to promote the
importance of peace.
In 1862, he sent Gustave Moynier, president
of the Geneva Society for Public Welfare,
a copy of his book A Memory of Solferino.
Moynier was touched by the book’s essence
and decided to invite Dunant to a special
meeting on February 9, 1863 of the Geneva
Society for Public Welfare.
Following this meeting, it was decided to
establish an International Committee for Relief
to the Wounded of War.
This organization became the International
Committee of the Red Cross.
Dunant served as a member of this committee
and worked as its Secretary for some years.
Another key facet of his work was the suggestion
that there was a need for, “a government
treaty recognizing the neutrality of the agency
and allowing it to provide aid in a war zone.”
This idea ultimately led to the first Geneva
Convention treaty.
While Dunant’s humanitarian work was producing
amazing fruits, his business and financial
affairs weren’t doing as well owing to nearly
complete neglect by Dunant.
By 1867, he was forced to declare bankruptcy.
Financially ruined and with debts exceeding
one million Swiss francs, he resigned from
his position as Secretary of the International
Committee.
On September 8, 1867 the Commission decided
to accept his resignation not only as Secretary,
but as a member as well.
In disgrace, Dunant went to Paris, where he
ended up sleeping on benches in the parks
and eating scraps of food where he could find
it.
But poverty did not stop his humanitarian
work.
During the Franco-Prussian war, he visited
and comforted the wounded who had been moved
to Paris, and introduced the use of armbands
to identify the dead.
At the end of the war, Dunant traveled to
London, where he sought to organize an international
conference concerning the problem of prisoners
of war, and even though the Tsar of Russia
encouraged him, England was against such a
project.
An international conference on the “total
and final abolition of the slave trade”
was launched in London on February 1, 1875,
also instigated by Dunant.
Of course, humanitarian work usually doesn’t
pay well, or at all in many cases, and years
of wandering and extreme poverty followed
for Dunant.
Through the years, he traveled on foot in
Germany, Italy and Alsace, living on donations
and the hospitality of friends and new acquaintances.
Finally, in 1887, Dunant found himself in
the Swiss village of Heiden, where he fell
seriously ill.
He found refuge in the local nursing home,
and it was here that he was discovered in
1895 by a journalist who wrote an article
about him.
A few days later, the article, and the fact
that Dunant was still alive which was news
to many, was republished throughout Europe.
Messages of sympathy and acclaim reached Dunant
from all over the world; Dunant was again
celebrated and honored, and in 1901, he received
the very first Nobel Peace Prize for his integral
role in the establishment of the Red Cross
as well as the first treat in what would become
known as the Geneva Conventions.
Now with the Nobel Peace Prize money in hand,
you might wonder if Dunant perhaps started
a new business with it to take himself out
of poverty and debt, or at the least move
out of the small nursing home room he’d
occupied for several years.
In fact, he did not.
He continued to live there for the rest of
his life.
As for the prize money, some 75,000 Swiss
Francs (about $375,000 today), he didn’t
spend any of it himself, leaving it untouched
in the account setup for him.
Upon his death nine years after winning the
prize, he left much of the money to various
charitable organizations, as well as to the
nursing home where he had been living with
the stipulation that they leave one free bed
open for the poorest of the community to use
in times of need.
He also left a certain amount to pay back
some of the debts he still had from back in
his business days.
Henry Dunant died in relative obscurity on
October 20, 1910.
As per his wishes, no funeral was held, nor
any other type of gathering celebrating his
life.
He simply requested that he be “carried
to his grave like a dog.”